[Applause]
yes my Keith the voice of the Tennessee
Titans for so many years calling one of
the more remarkable performances by any
human being on a football field and I'm
not just saying that because that very
large human being is sitting to my right
I would say even if he was sitting here
here on behalf of the FedEx Aaron ground
NFL players of the Year awards from the
Tennessee Titans Derrick Henry here on
the Rich Eisen show good to see you sir
how are you doing good how you doing hi
I'm doing great
yes sir what in the heck is it feel like
to do what you just did I mean what does
it feel like as a human being to just
Bowl people over and know that you are
creating business decisions left and
right for Europe oh it was fun
especially far as a team and doing what
we did but we didn't finish though no I
know this unfinished business I
understand we didn't finish so yes mama
no and I understand it's probably not
easy I've interviewed people who have
just missed the Superbowl but show up to
the Super Bowl to either a maintain
their commitments because they're a man
of their word or a woman of their word
and there's championship situations
where it's difficult to show up and I
understand that but you just I mean you
can sit back and room and take a look at
what you just did what you just did was
amazing
pre-show thank you so much you're very
welcome where I would say where did it
come from but we've seen footage of you
as a high schooler and obvious he had
Alabama did you hit a specific button
did you push something this year did
something clicked for you this year in a
manner that hadn't previously um I think
this I think with me every year I just
want to get better and I think I'm just
my main focus it's being better than I
was last year
well I sure wasn't great but I
definitely want to be better better this
year and then thinking about the whole
year I mean we were 24 24 so we look
like we weren't getting in the playoffs
in you know we locked in and put
ourselves in great position to get in
and we got in and my main focus just
doing my job at the best of my ability
to give us a chance to keep and make it
out here so why do you get stronger as
the game goes on
I think with the more I get the ball
more I get in the flow of my game and
then you know I just get rolling and
again what is it like where you're back
there you know you're gonna get it yeah
the eight in the box or nine in the box
that you see knows you're going to get
it yeah and you know you're gonna give
it to them
yeah and they know you're going to give
it to them what is that like for you I
just I just love the game I love having
a ball in my hands and I love making
plays and I don't know I just it's just
the game man like that feeling when you
when everybody knows and I can't stop it
it is undescribable feeling man and
that's just speaking for like us as a
team and you know I just I know you're
smiling you're smiling this it is just
it must be an amazing feeling a lot of
fun to have that ability Derek Henry
here on the Rich Eisen show
did you hear what Earl Thomas said
before the divisional playoff game in
Baltimore saying that the Patriots
didn't want to tackle you but they were
gonna have a different oh yes everybody
was sending it to me right was showing
it to me yes okay so now later on you're
in Baltimore you get the ball you're on
the edge did you know that was Earl
Thomas don't you give him a second shot
because it was Thomas yes I was
wondering cuz you gave him you gave him
one in the front and you gave him one
slightly unnecessary one in the back but
what's so funny about that is I also
focused on give him another sub that I
read myself out of bounds there's some
over the first time he kind of turned
around yeah and I could have turned up
bill but I also focus on this like give
him a soda I ran myself out of bounds
but yeah but yeah I definitely did that
because so then the last question is was
it worth it to run yourself out of
bounds I think it was
Derek Henry here on the Rich Eisen show
yes I thought so too that you were in
the moment like okay I remember this
I see who's coming at me and again I
love Earl Thomas I think he's gonna have
a bust in the Hall of Fame one - quietly
- but everybody's you're an
equal-opportunity everybody gets some
type running exactly I saw Eddie George
last night huh Derek and his psalm to
understand
by the way guys in HD literally looks
like he can't give me 30 cats right does
but what did what did he say to you that
helped you out and helped you know get
you ready for these moments like the
ones we just saw last year I wasn't
having a great year for like I was
trying to do too much trying to hit a
home run every play and um you know am i
play just one I just went in there and
um you know I've talked to Eddie you
know we do high school commercials in he
was that a couple of them on me talk got
to know each other a little more you
know I think it was like one night I was
home at the practice and I just text him
see if I can call him I called him and
asked him what he talked about my game
and he actually told me one good enough
and if it ain't if you know I'm fixing
ain't gonna have a job you know
basically I was running a song like I
needed to impose my will on defenders I
need to finish running to be physical
and let the game come to me instead of
trying to make a big play every time I
every time I touched the ball how'd you
take that oh I loved it you know I think
was like after the bye week we had a bye
week I think we had a game and then I
called him right before we paid like the
Patriots or something like that and you
know I was already evaluating myself and
I just took it over the top so there
wasn't a part of you that was just that
it was tough for you to hear no I rather
hear from a guy that's done at a high
level or players who don't have a high
level in his league that people respect
then you know sit there and you know
talk to myself about why don't you get
better as always good to hear some
whether it's you respecting am i Derrick
Henry here on the Rich Eisen show and
again we'll talk about the FedEx air and
ground
NFL players of the Year awards in a
second you're a free agent sir
correct sir what how are you approaching
this you
you're excited you're want to stay what
do you got for me uh I definitely want
to stay go come
I miss my first time being a free agent
and this is taking one day at a time and
then you know see what happens
yes I mean eventually I mean something's
gonna happen so ain't no reason to rush
in it right now just just let it play
out give my agent talked to the team and
then see I see how it goes from there so
I'm new to this so okay Zeke numbers the
floor is that the floor think numbers is
the floor that's it right I mean he's
the guy so do you have a place in Cabo
that you can go to as well to pull the Z
actually was actually it was at a Provo
I had we went out even we're talking to
catching up so this past propo what you
what you talk about it dinner football
talk about life no discussion of all
those great things strategy a little
strategy well again he had a contract
you have you are a free agent I mean huh
so you you can pretty much dictate in a
way what you would like to have happen
and so you will test the market or is a
way that Tennessee could prevent that
from happening it's what you're selling
me I hope they prevent it from happening
now a lot of times love to stay in
Tennessee and and then see what happens
though I mean you know it's all I mean
gotta talk to my agent where are things
out with them and you know okay and you
you led the league in carries and and
yards so you have pretty much put your
resume on the table for the Tennessee
Titans
so have you ever played a game where you
think you got too many Karan's I have
not no never where you're like come on
I've been carrying the ball a lot since
high school so it's like it's not like
oh I got to at 57 in high school so
ain't nothing gonna get too bad what's
the most pissed you ever made Nick Saban
oh I got a funny story so um it was my
last year at Bama think we were at the
camp and that Bama we do we do team run
a period called team run and team runs
like a game we all take a serious so
it's offense versus defense and coach
save you know coach telling the TV is a
minor code so he's all locked in
we want to do good on team running on I
think I was only at that time I was the
only one that was like healthy and all
my other backs were mixing bruza or hurt
so I was only doing team run and I think
I did like we did like four we did like
four plays and like I think three out of
the four I like broke through a guy had
some good runs and consumer got mad and
I think on the forefront he started it
over and I was gasps I was like I was so
tired and then uh Lincoln was off as a
coordinator song start right now I'm
like anybody else can get in and in it
Ryan besides me and cuz I started all
started over and I'm and I'm yelling
sorry that it's so close salmon coming
over is I should hope you do until you
do dissing it at Miss now I was like
okay coach you got anger anger saying
that so that was that that was the
moment why was he so pissed off because
you were you you you didn't want to do
all four or you were just dominating I
don't know like what would what do you
piss him off about it was - it get
better at this I think your day to be
pissed off at you is that basically what
it might have been with Nick Saban I
think it was just hey you need to get
better so let's get better now it's
alright cuz cuz one of my favorite
stories Iowa I heard from Commissioner
Paul Tagliabue
you know was the Commissioner before
Roger Goodell told me a story about Bill
Parcells and he went to a Jets practice
and watched Parcells do the Parcells
thing which was stand on the 50-yard
line and bark at everybody doing goal
line drills 50 yards away you know
getting on everybody and tackle evil
goes we're the same age I can hardly see
five yards downfield
how can you see 50 yards down the field
he goes oh I can't he took out a list of
10 names he goes I'm out gonna get on
these ten guys on practice today I'm on
number six stick around more to go
alright so tell me about the FedEx
errand ground NFL players of the Year
award you are clearly up for the FedEx
Ground Player of the Year
award what do you what are you doing for
this you just yeah playing airplane T
and ground Player of the Year no you can
vote at a nfl.com slash FedEx you've
gone NFL Twitter to vote voting ends at
3:00 p.m. so go vote make sure you go
vote yes and on behalf of FedEx dear
don't name $20,000 each I'm half for the
air and ground players of the year
that's a great thing FedEx is doing it
for the US oh yeah that is very great
I said voting ends at 3:00 p.m. make
sure you go vote you know no finish
doing the great car but don't name that
money into USO so I'm just happy to be
happy there
okay so I'm not going to ask you who the
other Player of the Year nominees are
the running back position i won't i
won't i won't i won't say including
christian McCaffrey's here tomorrow and
it's kind of not fair that he's your dog
okay understand that all day okay and
chub is the other guy alright did you
say
who would you vote for for the air award
Jackson mahomes Russell Wilson who would
you vote tomorrow
you didn't stutter anymore he is the MVP
of the enemy well you just saw my homes
up close and personal what do you think
what do you think the 49ers have to deal
with this company I was on first second
I picked the 49ers to win cuz I just I
mean I feel like as a team to beat
factor homes and achieved in that's the
team that that can do it and meaning
pressure Holmes is good as advertised
Ally whatever you want to say here is
that right no I've seen that you know up
close to a person or so that's you have
a second tank or second take on this or
you're going to stick with the 49ers but
you know that person that wants the team
that beat you to go win it all you know
it's not I'm not I'm not rooting against
him I just think that I like I like what
the 49ers do and I think that I think
that they that could beat the Chiefs but
again it's hard I think against bachelor
homes and what he does and I offered to
have so many weapons and they I feel
like their defense feed off their office
but once that gets going you and if
you're playing from behind and I think
it's around all right and I've got Joe
borrow on tomorrow's show did you vote
for him for the
yeah jobber did what a season he had he
had a great season so you hear he was
first and foremost because well hurt so
I mean that was the first time in a very
long time it was clear cut who was the
one that trophy but it was his from yeah
right from the very year hey Derek
Congrats on a huge season I mean just a
huge season I know you came up short but
you know the consolation prize I guess
is for you to appear on bus and with the
boys with Taylor - Juan yeah and we'll
Compton I haven't done it yet no you
know I'm not gonna do it until he
actually puts a motor in his bus oh my
god we still the guy luan has a pot with
will Compton who gets pissed off but I
try to make people better okay I'm
trying to make people better and if he's
got something closer listen with the
boys that you can't actually eat you're
in the husk of a bus with no motor in it
I can't unless you bring your own chair
you see so you can feel comfortable at
home would you you might be able to work
it in this way but again he's he's got a
maybe cuz maybe because he's too busy
protecting you he can't figure out how
to put how about how about how about
I'll do it interview first you know
check it out look over the place and
then I'll let you know I'll I say okay
so you in other words you're my lead
blocker got sit on this from God see I
like it very good please do that Derek
cuz again I you know I'm a man of
principles I cannot be on a podcast
that's taped in a boss when the bus
doesn't move it's just ridiculous the
bus is located in Tennessee and I live
in LA so let's check it out Thank You
Derek Henry at King Henry underscore 2
on Twitter at last underscore King
underscore 2 on Instagram
that's right here on the Rich Eisen show
Steve Mariucci Jason Witten and Michael
Strahan still to come on this day for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 under red TV for
free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app